texas is not the only said experiencing
the brunt of this crisis however arizona
border patrol agents this week
seizing more than 50 pounds of fentanyl
hidden under a truck bed
local officials continue to sound the
alarm calling for more resources cochise
county arizona sheriff mark danelles is
with me now sheriff it's been a while
since we have spoken thank you for
coming back uh the 50 pounds of fentanyl
seized in one truck near tucson what are
we going to do about this
well bill they've set us up for failure
here on the southwest border completely
and let me give you some numbers bill
that kind of highlights what's going on
uh this fiscal year we've had 10 000
pounds of fentanyl 180 000 pounds of
meth 86 thousand pounds of cocaine five
thousand pounds of heroin and three
hundred eleven thousand pounds of
marijuana come through the southwest
border this fiscal year
the war on drug
drugs is back and until america steps up
on this and secures this border it's
only going to get worse wow the war on
drugs in america is back that is quite a
statement when you think about what we
went through to try and bring that war
to a halt 33 year old female u.s citizen
was the driver of that vehicle
sir also we have this image of four and
six-year-old girls in yuma found what do
you know about these two wandering in
the desert alone
and this is very common on the west side
of our state arizona where the cartels
are dropping children into these
communities with notes
to say here's where you connect them
back to the family this is all cartel
driven profit greedy
individual criminal enterprises running
this it's very very sad that's the
humanitarian side of this bill that's
not being told also the other aspect of
this i will say that just in arizona
alone we've had 162
migrant deaths in our southern part of
our state 162 this year alone so again
the humanitarian side of this is is real
no doubt
uh the remaining mexico policy proved to
be quite successful for the previous
administration and this administration
kicked it to the curb the judge is
saying you must reinstate it it's our
understanding by administration we'll
get back to this in the month of
november however there is a massive
caveat on that and that is mexico has to
accept the terms of this deal
how successful was remain in mexico as a
program
and do you expect it to come back next
month
it's it was very successful bill i mean
you look where we're at
today compared to a little over a year
ago we're up
325 percent increase on our southwest
border 1.4 million encounters on the
southwest border and then you look at in
my section of the state the southeast
corner state of arizona we get 10 000 a
month getaways these are people being
smugglers single
male adults 20 30 year olds that are
being smuggled in the country they get
away every month 10 000 a month 1100 a
day along the southwest border uh the
the southwest border is the largest
crime scene in this country right now if
people look at the totality of what's
going on here
the largest crime scene in america
wow
[Music]
and and i say that bill because you look
at public safety you look at national
security and you look humanitarian not
even talking about the health uh issues
that were addressed on the southwest
border
it is a
mess let me just say that is a mess
caused by this administration that have
willful neglect its willful acts by them
is what's causing this problem the
messaging is not there and there is no
consequences sheriff we got to clean it
up i mean two things you said in this
interview are just astounding and the
war on drugs is back
uh real head scratcher and the largest
crime scene in america you're probably
right about it sheriff good luck all
right we're gonna stay on the topic
we'll stay on the issue we'll stay in
contact with people like you thank you
sir thank you hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now